Hungría es como Rusia pero baja en calorías
¿Tienen corrupción?
Sí, pero no llegan al nivel de Rusia ¿Es
un gobierno autoritario?
Pues sí, cada vez más.
Pero...
no llegan al nivel de envenenar a los opositores
políticos con Novichok.
No deja de ser un país de la Unión Europea,
es decir, con unas mínimas garantías democráticas.
El presidente de Hungría es este señor que
veis en pantalla, VIKTOR ORBAN: el principal
aliado de Putin en Europa.
Podríamos decir que Orban es el enfant terrible
de Bruselas: autoritario, ultra conservador
y pro Putin.
Vamos, un partidazo.
Y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando muchos:
este vídeo va ser una crítica sin sentido
a Orban ¿Verdad?
Por alguna razón, recibimos muchos comentarios
que nos acusan de estar financiados por George
Soros.
Y como todo el mundo sabe, Orban es el archienemigo
de Soros.
Así que... blanco y en botella: ¡Seguro
que este vídeo está pagado por Soros para
que mostremos las vergüenzas del presidente
de Hungría!
¿Verdad?
(Paréntesis: ¿Alguna vez os habéis preguntado
por qué George Soros es tan conocido?
Al final de este vídeo os lo contaremos).
Pero lo cierto es que siento decepcionaros
pero en el vídeo de hoy no vamos a insultar
a Orban.
Vamos a centrarnos en la otra cara de Hungría
¿De qué estamos hablando?
De esto.
Viktor Orbán gana, por cuarta vez consecutiva,
las elecciones para Primer Ministro de Hungría
¡Habéis oído bien!
4 victorias electorales consecutivas.
Viktor Orban lleva más de 12 años en el
poder.
Y cada vez que va a las urnas, arrasa.
Estas últimas elecciones, las de 2022, tienen
merito.
En este caso, casi todos los partidos políticos,
desde la EXTREMA DERECHA hasta los socialdemócratas,
se aliaron en una coalición para intentar
derrotarle ¿Resultado?
No sólo ha ganado: es que ha ganado por mayoría
absoluta otra vez.
En otras palabras ¿Queréis ganar elecciones?
Poned un Orban en vuestras vidas.
Este hombre gana las elecciones hasta para
presidente de la Comunidad de vecinos.
Y sí, habéis oído bien: GANA las elecciones.
Como hemos dicho antes, Hungría es como Rusia
pero baja en calorías.
Eso significa que las elecciones son relativamente
libres.
Cierto, el partido de Orban, el FIDESZ, ha
hecho algunas pequeñas trampas.
Pero hay que reconocer la realidad como es:
Orban no necesita maquillar los datos.
Es realmente popular en su país.
La pregunta es ¿Por qué?
¿Cuál es el secreto detrás del éxito de
Viktor Orban?
¿Hay alguna lección que podamos aprender
de Hungría?
¿Y por qué George Soros es tan conocido
en todo el mundo?
Hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero
antes…
¿Sabéis cómo podéis apoyar a VisualPolitik
de forma activa?
Pues entrando en nuestra comunidad de Patreon.
No sólo estaréis contribuyendo a que VisualPolitik
siga adelante.
Además, tendréis acceso a merchandising
como…
¡Esta camiseta que llevo puesta!
No está a la venta.
La única forma de conseguirla es formando
parte de nuestra comunidad ¡Pero no sólo
eso!
También tenemos una newsletter semanal; las
claves de la semana, donde tratamos temas
que no nos da tiempo a cubrir en forma de
vídeos.
Además, también estamos subiendo contenido
exclusivo.
Por ejemplo, ahí hemos publicado otro vídeo
sobre Hungría y George Soros donde profundizamos
en temas que no nos da tiempo a cubrir en
este.
Así que, ya sabéis, si no os lo queréis
perder…
¡Os espero en la comunidad de VisualPolitik
en Patreon!
Y ahora sí, vamos a ver un poco de historia.
¡ES LA ECONOMÍA, ESTÚPIDO!
¿Os suena un software que se llama ArchiCAD?
Si trabajáis en algo relacionado con la arquitectura,
seguro que lo habéis usado alguna vez.
Es uno de los softwares de referencia.
Pues bien, está hecho en Hungría.
Con este ejemplo os podéis hacer una idea
de que la economía de Hungría tiene mucho
potencial.
Tienen un sector IT importante, un sector
farmacéutico importante y industria.
Dicho de otra forma: no es un país rico como
pueda ser Alemania o Suecia pero sí son una
de las economías postcomunistas más exitosas,
al nivel de Polonia o República Checa.
Ahora bien, cuando Orban llegó al poder,
Hungría atravesaba una enorme crisis económica.
Corría el año 2010 y Hungría era uno de
los países más afectados por la gran crisis
financiera.
Tenían un 11% de paro: la tasa más alta
junto a España.
7% de deficit: muy por encima de los requisitos
de Europa.
Vamos, que Orban tenía un montón de trabajo
por delante ¿Y cuál fue su receta para salvar
la economía?
Pues podríamos decir que Orban hizo lo opuesto
a lo que haría cualquier gobierno de centro-izquierda.
Vamos a decirlo claro: Orban es ultra nacionalista
y no le gusta que vengan personas del extranjero...
ahora bien: cuando hablamos de dinero, la
cosa cambia totalmente.
Básicamente, la receta de Orban tiene dos
pilares: reducción del gasto público y alfombra
roja al capital extranjero.
Y en este aspecto, hay que reconocer que Hungría
es todo un caso de éxito.
Atentos a esta gráfica:
Si os fijáis, veréis que Hungría es capaz
de atraer más dinero del extranjero que otros
países como Alemania o Polonia.
Casi el 75% de la inversión industrial en
este país viene del extranjero.
Y, tras la llegada al poder de Orban, este
país ha registrado sus mayores picos.
Y la pregunta es ¿Por qué?
¿Qué tiene Hungría que no tengan otros
países?
La primera respuesta son impuestos.
Si pensamos en países con impuestos bajos,
nos vienen a la cabeza Irlanda o Luxemburgo...
pero lo cierto es que Hungría tiene el impuesto
de sociedades más bajo de toda Europa.
Fijaos en este mapa.
Desde el año 2017, las empresa húngaras
pagan un simple 9% de impuesto de sociedades.
A todo esto hay que añadirla toda clase de
programas de subsidios y deducciones fiscales.
Por ejemplo, si una empresa reinvierte sus
beneficios en startups Húngaras, pueden llegar
a ahorrarse hasta un 80% de impuestos.
Si a esto le sumamos que Hungría tiene mano
de obra bien formada y sueldos relativamente
baratos, es fácil entender que este país
no deje de atraer dinero de fuera.
Para que os hagáis una idea, son el segundo
país de toda la Unión Europea en atraer
inversión de Corea del Sur ¡Ojo!
Esto no significa que Corea del Sur sea el
principal inversor de Hungría ni mucho menos.
Pero sirve como ejemplo para ver cómo las
empresas de países tan remotos como Corea
del Sur apuestan por Hungría mucho más que
otros países.
Dicho de otra forma: sí, Viktor Orban puede
ser la oveja negra de la familia Bruselita...
pero los resultados de sus políticas no son
tan malos.
Sí, es cierto, puede que Orban sea el hombre
que haría llorar a Greta Thumbnerg.
Pero, cuando las empresas que fabrican coches
eléctricos elijen un destino para sus fábricas,
prefieren Hungría antes que muchos otros
países ¡Habéis oído bien!
Desde el año 2021, Hungría se está colocando
a la vanguardia del coche eléctrico.
Al menos en Europa.
Atentos.
BMW construirá una planta de 1.000 millones
de euros para fabricar coches eléctricos
en Hungría
Mercedes benz lanzará la producción en serie
de un eléctrico puramente eléctrico en Hungría
¡Y ya sé lo que estará pensando alguno!
Bien: Hungría puede ser un paraíso para
las empresas pero...
¿De verdad todo ese dinero llega al bolsillo
del húngaro de a pie?
Pues los datos hablan por si solos.
Voy a daros una comparativa: en el año 2010,
España tenía un desempleo del 19% mientras
que Hungría estaba en el 11%.
10 años más tarde, en 2020, España estaba
en un 15% mientras que Hungría apenas superaba
el 4% ¡No sólo eso!
Todo este crecimiento económico se ha traducido
en más dinero para el estado y cuentas más
saneadas.
Y diréis ¿En qué se ha gastado este dinero?
¿Cómo funcionan las políticas sociales
de Orban?
Ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
VALORES FAMILIARES
¡Ya sé lo que estaréis pensando muchos!
¡Viktor Orban no es más que un populista
de derechas!
Toda su política económica se puede resumir
en bajar impuestos ¡Así cualquiera tiene
contentos a los ciudadanos!
Pues lo cierto es que no.
De hecho, si tuviéramos que definir de algún
modo la política fiscal de Hungría sería
con anti populismo.
Sí, es cierto, las empresas pagan menos impuestos
que en ningún país europeo (Recordad que
las empresas no votan).
Sin embargo, casi todo el esfuerzo fiscal
recae en el ciudadano medio ¿Cómo?
Con el impuesto más impopular que existe:
el IVA y los impuestos indirectos.
Si Hungría tiene los impuestos de sociedades
más bajos de Europa, en lo que a impuestos
indirectos se refiere es todo lo contrario:
27% ¡Habéis oído bien!
Mientras la mayoría de los países europeos
tienen un 21% de impuestos, Hungría tiene
un machacante 27%.
Podréis criticar esta política.
Pero desde luego, no podemos decir que es
un intento de comprar a los votantes.
Más bien todo lo contrario.
Y la pregunta es ¿A dónde va todo ese dinero
que se recauda?
¿Qué políticas sociales hay en Hungría?
Pues aquí es donde podríamos hablar de una
especie de socialdemocracia conservadora.
Aquí es donde Orban muestra su cara más
tradicional.
Porque casi todas las políticas sociales
están orientadas a un único gol: ¡¡¡TENED
MÁS HIJOS!!!
Sí, habéis oído bien.
La crisis de las pensiones es un problema
en toda Europa: incluída Hungría.
Y la receta de Orban para evitar el decrecimiento
demográfico se basa en intentar por todos
los medios que los Húngaros se pongan a tener
hijos.
Por ejemplo, desde el año 2012, las familias
con más de 4 hijos no pagan impuesto de la
renta.
Así.
Tal cual.
0% de impuestos de la renta ¡Pero no sólo
eso!
Dentro de la pareja, la madre que ha dado
a luz a 4 hijos está libre de pagar impuestos...
¡Para toda la vida!
¿Y qué pasa con las familias que no tienen
4 hijos?
Pues, por ejemplo, las familias con entre
3 y 4 hijos que compran una furgoneta, tienen
una subvención de alrededor de 7000 dólares.
En otras palabras: la política de Orban es
extremadamente social.
Sí, cierto, son ayudas sociales condicionadas
a tener hijos.
Pero son ayudas que llegan a la amplia mayoría
de los húngaros ¡Y no creáis que hablamos
de poco dinero!
En 2019, los llamados programas de protección
de la familia llegaron a suponer el 4,8% de
todo el PIB Húngaro.
Y la pregunta que todos os estaréis haciendo
ahora es...
¿De verdad están funcionando estas políticas?
¿De verdad Hungría está consiguiendo acabar
con el invierno demográfico?
Y la respuesta es...
un claro y rotundo NO.
Atentos a esta gráfica.
Aquí podéis ver cómo la tasa de fertilidad
en Hungría sigue prácticamente igual con
o sin políticas de natalidad.
Las mujeres húngaras tienen una media de
1,6 hijos.
En otras palabras: la población húngara
sigue decreciendo ¡Ahora bien!
En lo que a reducción de la desigualdad se
refiere, Orban es todo un genio.
Atentos a esta gráfica.
Aquí podéis ver cómo las diferencias entre
ricos y pobres son mucho más suaves en Hungría
que en Francia o Alemania ¡Ojo!
Esto no es una apología de Orban ni mucho
menos.
Pero más de uno en Bruselas debería echar
un vistazo a estos datos.
Por ejemplo: desde el año 2021, el mundo
entero se ha sumido en una espiral inflacionista
¿Cuál ha sido la respuesta de Orban?
Poner precios máximos a los bienes más básicos:
cosas muy específicas pero que suponen la
piedra angular de la dieta de alguien con
pocos ingresos.
Por ejemplo, las pechugas de pollo, el aceite
de girasol o la leche tienen precios máximos
¿Y cuál ha sido la respuesta de Orban para
luchar contra la crisis energética?
Atentos.
Precios máximos al combustible: envían propuestas
al gobierno para salvar a las gasolineras
Vamos a ser claros ¿Son estas las mejores
políticas para luchar contra la inflación?
En realidad no.
Pero, al menos en el corto plazo, los ciudadanos
más pobres de Hungría ven que su gobierno
está actuando.
Sí, es verdad, nunca veréis a Orban en la
cabalgata del orgullo gay.
Su retórica está muy lejos de lo que en
cualquier otro país se entendería por política
social.
Pero nadie puede negar que su gobierno está
haciendo todo lo posible por ayudar a las
familias más desfavorecidas.
Y eso se nota en las elecciones ¡Y ya sé
lo que estará pensando alguno!
En VIsualPolitik estamos poniendo a Orban
por las nubes ¿No será el Gobierno de Hungría
el que nos está pagando bajo cuerda?
Tranquilos.
Ahora vamos a contar la otra cara de Orban.
La que no cuentan ni los medios húngaros
ni los medios mainstream.
Atentos.
EL HOMBRE QUE “CREÓ” A GEORGE SOROS
George Soros es algo así como el Elvis Presley
de las conspiraciones.
No hay teoría de la conspiración donde no
aparezca Soros por algún lado.
Probablemente todos los que veáis este vídeo
le habréis oído mentar en algún momento.
La pregunta es ¿Por qué es tan famoso?
Me explico: George Soros es un multimillonario
con mucha influencia política.
Sí, cierto.
Pero no es ni el más rico del mundo ni el
más influyente ¿Por qué todo el mundo conoce
a Soros y no, por ejemplo, a los Hermanos
Koch?
La respuesta está en Viktor Orban.
O más bien, en el estratega política que
creó el mito de Viktor Orban.
Y diréis ¿Pero qué tiene que ver este buen
señor con Orban o con Soros?
Pues veréis: la carrera política de Orban
tiene dos etapas bien diferenciadas.
Desde el año 1998 hasta 2002, Viktor Orban
fue primer ministro de Hungría.
En este caso, podríamos definirlo como un
político liberal.
Sin embargo, en 2002 perdió las elecciones.
Durante 8 años estuvo en la oposición.
Ahí es cuando contrató los servicios de
Arthur Finkelstein.
Arthur Finkelstein era un consultor de comunicación
política de Estados Unidos...
mejor dicho: podríamos decir que Arthur Finkelstein,
Karl Rove y Lee Atwater son como el Frank
Sinatra, Dean Martin y Sammy Davis Jr. de
la consultoría política: unos auténticos
genios del arte de ganar elecciones.
Pues bien, Finkelstein fue quien dibujó la
nueva imagen de Orban: un hombre del pueblo,
que pasa los fines de semana en el campo y
bebe palinka.
Pero, como ya sabéis los que seguís VisualPolitik
desde hace tiempo, para crear un héroe en
política, hay que crear un villano ¿Y quién
era el villano perfecto para Orban?
Pues nada más y nada menos que George Soros.
Aunque no sea el inversor más rico del mundo
ni mucho menos...
nació en Hungría.
Tal vez sea el húngaro más rico del mundo.
Y el odio contra los millonarios es un arma
electoral tan antigua como las promesas imposibles
de cumplir.
A esto hay que sumarle que siempre ha sido
crítico con Orban y que es judío, lo que
agita el fervor antisemita de los húngaros.
En otras palabras: Soros era el villano perfecto.
Y eso explica declaraciones como esta.
En un discurso, Orban ataca al enemigo que
especula con dinero
Orban: Europa no debe sucumbir a la red de
Soros
Por cierto, si queréis comprender más toda
la historia de quién es George Soros y cómo
se creó el mito, hemos sacado un vídeo exclusivo
para Patreon donde lo tratamos en profundidad.
Así que ya tenéis otra razón más para
entrar en nuestra comunidad en Patreon.
Pero volvamos con nuestra historia porque
hay otro as que Orban se guarda en la manga.
Otra arma especial para ganar elecciones.
Fuera de Hungría hay más de 2,4 millones
de húngaros étnicos.
Es decir, en Rumanía, Eslovaquia y Eslovenia
hay muchas comunidades de hungaro-parlantes.
Durante años, Orban les ha dado pasaporte
para que puedan votar en las elecciones.
Y todos ellos votan masivamente al partido
de Orban, el FIDESZ.
Y diréis ¿Es esto manipulación electoral?
Pues sí y no.
Pero nadie puede negar que Orban conoce muy
bien a su votante.
Por ejemplo, en un momento donde todo el mundo
parece estar muy concienciado con la guerra
de Ucrania, Orban ha sabido hacer una lectura
tan arriesgada como certera.
Rompiendo filas con la UE, Hungría está
lista para pagar el gas ruso en rublos
¡Exacto!
Hungría es el país de la Unión Europea
más cercano a la Rusia de Putin.
Desde el punto de vista ético, es una auténtica
vergüenza.
Pero los números están ahí.
El votante medio en Hungría ha votado con
el bolsillo.
Y la cercanía de Orban con Putin se traduce
en gas y petróleo más barato que en cualquier
otro país europeo.
Al menos en el corto plazo.
Y diréis ¿Pero qué puede pasar en el largo
plazo?
Pues aquí es donde llega el gran problema
de las Orbanomics.
Durante años, Budapest ha tensado la cuerda
con Bruselas.
Y su postura en la guerra de Ucrania podría
ser la gota que colme el vaso ¿Puede la Unión
Europea sancionar a Hungría?
Vamos a volver a echar un vistazo a esta gráfica.
Si os fijáis en el año 2004 hay un salto
sustancial en la cantidad de dinero que llega
a Hungría ¿Qué pasó en 2004?
¡Exacto!
Hungría entró en la Unión Europea.
Las empresas del resto de Europa son las principales
inversoras en Hungría.
En otras palabras: el éxito político y económico
de Orban está atado a la Unión Europa.
La pregunta es ¿Qué puede pasar si todo
ese grifo de inversión se corta de golpe?
¿Hasta qué punto la postura de Hungría
con la guerra de Ucrania puede ser el principio
del fin de la era Orban?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Como siempre, no olvidéis que aquí, en VisualPolitik,
sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así
que suscribíos a este canal y dadle a la
campanita para no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones.
Recordad que también tenemos contenido exclusivo,
newsletter y merchandising en nuestra comunidad
de Patreon.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo.
Un abrazo y hasta pronto.